arthur bataille bonjour bonjour vous
êtes si haut de six comme s'il a alors
silicum est un acteur de la
cybersécurité sur saint quentin en
yvelines
votre actualité c'est la plateforme
sylla de e-learning parce que vous
lancez un campus de formation
tout à fait on a l'espoir de lancer à
partir du premier semestre 2009 un
incident est un lieu de cyber
entraînement donc l'objectif c'est en
partenariat avec le groupe airbus
défense n space services cybersécurité
de lancer un lieu d'innovation qui va
permettre à des étudiants de venir se
former dans nos locaux c'est destiné au
grand public là vous parlez d'étudiants
c'est des personnes qui ont déjà des
connaissances dans l'informatique alors
dans un premier temps on s'adresse
plutôt à des gens qui ont déjà une
expertise dans le milieu de
l'informatique donc que ce soit dans la
partie et réseaux ou système et après on
évoluera pour faire des parcours entre
guillemets d'accompagnement et de
formation
depuis entre guillemets des personnes
qui vont être très novice dans lieux
l'informatique jusqu'à un niveau
d'expertisé dans le domaine de la
cybersécurité en quoi vont consister ces
formations alors globalement on
utilisera la plateforme sylla pour toute
la partie learning et tout
l'accompagnement sur les bases sur le
système d'information sur le réseau sur
la sécurité de manière générale et on
utilisera derrière l'accès à la
plate-forme d'airbus cyber security donc
la saib orange pour mettre en place des
cas pratiques et dessiner des scénarios
de crise dans le monde à la
cybersécurité un dernier mot vous dites
que ça sera lancée au premier semestre
2020 comment on fait pour s'inscrire
comment on peut participer à cette
formation assez simplement sur la
plateforme si l' on nous ont répondu à
notre questionnaire est notre formulaire
de prise de contact est également en
nous contactant directement sur notre
site de guyancourt
les portes sont ouvertes n'hésitez pas à
venir d'ailleurs arthur bataille vous
m'avez par préparer une séance de
formation avec davy demontès oui
exactement vous allez être mis entre
guillemets les mains dans le cambouis et
vous allez voir ce que c'est le métier
de la sécurité une première initiation
[Musique]
nous allons rejoindre david montes
bonjour bonjour vous êtes ingénieur
pédagogique spécialisée dans le
numérique et notamment
vous travaillez pour sylla la plateforme
de e-learning deux formations à la
cybersécurité alors qu'est ce qu'on va
apprendre aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui nous allons voir avec sylla
comment générer une attaque surimpose
windows ça c'est une façon de tester les
connaissances des gens qui vont
travailler justement à rendre le système
plus robustes pour éviter les attaques
du coup ils vont voir comment ça marche
pour ensuite derrière ils vont apprendre
à se prémunir contre ces attaques
alors comment ça se passe d'abord on va
dans la plateforme sylla qui est notre
base de connaissances
nous allons voir la partie 6 vers nous
avons audit pentest c'est justement la
partie que nous allons faire pour tester
les systèmes et nous allons voir un
cours qui s'appelle attaques simples sur
un poste windows
donc je vois durée totale du court 20
minutes avec plusieurs prérequis savoir
utiliser une distribution linux donc il
faut avoir un minimum de connaissances
en informatique oui la plateforme sylla
c'est le une plateforme pour les experts
pour apprendre à renforcer leurs
connaissances pour mieux travailler dans
les entreprises
c'est quoi une map et maps est un outil
de ce qui permet aux personnes qui font
le pentest scanner le réseau
c'est-à-dire de voir qu'est ce qui est
possible qu'est ce qui est ouvert
quelles sont les différentes portes
d'entrée à un ordinateur ou un réseau il
ya metasploit qui est un tri morte c'est
à dire c'est une espèce de bibliothèques
d'attac qui permet d'automatiser les
attaques du justement de qui permet de
lancer des façons simples des attaques
sur un des équipes qu'on connaît
l'apprenant il a parcouru tout
l'exercice l'a vu ce qu'il faut faire
maintenant il va sur la 5 sur l'exercice
du coup donc on va sur la plateforme
siberian d'airbus ça c'est les
ordinateurs qui sont sur ces réseaux
c'est le réseau qu'on va attaquer on va
attaquer cet ordinateur
le pc 4 oui à partir de duquel il a
d'abord on dit on va réaliser le cedi la
première partie du line-up le même map
on va faire les scans du réseau si nous
avons une deux trois quatre cinq six
sept huit neuf réponse notre réponse
d'ouverture donc de systèmes
potentiellement attaquable c'est un seul
système qui est neuf portes ouvertes par
lesquels on peut attaquer on peut
s'introduire on va aller vers metasploit
metasploit c'est ce qui va permettre de
faire connaître de faire la tacc alors
elle a consisté en quoi cette attaque du
coup à s'introduire dans l'ordinateur
comme administrateur du coup on aura le
pouvoir de créer des utilisateurs de
leur donner le statut administrateurs
voir qu'ils sont qui sont les
utilisateurs utilisateurs on va voir
il existe le groupe administrateur
il existe donc l'attaqué réussie
l'attaqué réussie on a pénétré les
systèmes on a créé un utilisateur
on lui a donné des droits
d'administration il peut faire ce qu'il
veut
merci david montès